California has more than 8500
coronavirus cases and the number of
patients in intensive care
well that's nearly tripled Governor
Gavin Newsom says the crisis would be
much worse if the state had not taken
strong action only on CBS this morning
our anna warner spoke with the governor
about the latest numbers in California
what does that data say to you it's too
early for me to judge it but the reality
is this state was quick to move on
social distancing as a consequence I
think some of those early actions may
prove fruitful early actions meant
locking down the San Francisco Bay Area
on March 17th the entire state days
later all to slow the pace of infections
to give the state a precious resource
time what is it about the time that is
so important times everything every hour
every minute of every hour every day is
a day we're never gonna get back what
that time bought him Newsom says was a
chance to bring in more equipment and
this week thousands more medical
personnel every single day is the
opportunity to save lives and so that's
what we have bought here in California
and that's what I am currently focused
on not the models I want to prepare for
the worst Los Angeles County has not
seen the worst yet but already cases are
under investigation at a teen nursing
homes at one home in San Bernardino
County outside LA two people have died
more than 50 are infected Los Angeles
Mayor Eric Garcetti is preparing
residents for the long haul it will last
at least two months could last a third
and remember there's not just a light
switch that goes on and light comes back
to normal
statewide nurses are protesting a
serious shortage of protective gear
there aren't enough ventilators and the
governor worries about something harder
to fix I worry most to be candid with
you about fatigue I worry that people
saying you know what we got this let's
have that birthday party and let's mix
some of the extended cousins together if
we do that too soon or in trouble you
talked about a parachute it's the
equivalent to quite literally being a
parachute
and cutting the cord before you land no
one their right mind would do that in
this emergency California is hoping for
the softest landing possible for CBS
this morning and a Warner Sacramento